I was in the model party scene the coke
the crystal the private flames I think
we got out of there at the right time
I'm just glad you're here thank God for
Aaron he was always the grounded one and
when I hit rock bottom he was there to
pick me out why is it important to share
that story with people when you are in a
show like this you have to show your
life owning your past is a huge part of
growth and I think a lot of people for
many years I didn't I hit it I put on
this great show for everyone I wear
these beautiful masks tried to be
perfect but inside I was carrying all
these secrets and all the shame so with
a show like this in the magnitude of it
I can only be authentic and if I did not
speak about that part of my life I would
be hiding something
was it addiction or was it just dabbling
in drugs it was an addiction it was
slowly was becoming that way when I talk
about my come to Jesus moment on the
bathroom floor in this little apartment
right here in West Hollywood I was I was
abusing vicodin and alcohol and and now
knowing the how highly addictive
vicodin am and I was going down that
slippery slope and I think that that
happened to me on that bathroom floor to
keep me from going that far what
happened in the bathroom I was sweating
so profusely and I'm not a sweater
I was just drenched I felt like I had
five to ten daggers hot daggers in my
stomach my vision was blurry my mouth
was so dry I literally thought I was
dying I literally thought I was dying
and and then I cried out to God so
that's why I have to talk about it
because I'm not the only one it's not
like this is a special thing for me this
has happened to a lot of people but
people need that voice out there you
understand yeah
you